you
okay let's try it again okay how can i
trick this thing hmm let's see
hmm well let's go with this all right
I've had this good success against uh no
I don't know if I'd say good better than
other variations though when it plays
this move Queen C 1 and then Bishop h6
get rid of their Bishop ok and now get
in III Bishop e2 get castled quickly
before it's too late that I have to
anticipate this file opening up ok so
now I go here and let me make sure
there's not going to be f4 and what more
ok this night might think about jumping
in here if I push the knight pushing him
to better square I want to keep this
sitting this weakens the b5 square I
could make use of that but not so sure
that it's great let's try it though no
no no
if I do a three trying to get in rook
here and be 483 is met with a four or is
it actually a four Queen c2 yeah now
it's doing nothing
let me slowly I just want to inch my way
forward let's get clean here then one
huh let's get this move in
I want to secure this square for my
knight yeah it's shuffling now I want to
get my knight here so let me move my
bishop as soon as I move my knight a
four could be played let me do this to
reinforce c4 so that when my knight
moves this is gonna be covered now twice
okay my rook is unprotected Knight here
could still be met with this so I might
need to do this King F 1 2 G 2 actually
my rook
this move is already ready to be played
but I think it's working out I think
time wise were okay g5 King here and
then I'm threatening this so I have this
move in let's go there it's making a lot
of passing type of moves get my knight
in here bishop here I'm back to trying
to improve slowly all of my pieces if it
ever makes this h5 move that would be
wonderful
for the time but this is like a pseudo
outpost on f4 there's still ideas of h6
g5 for as long as he's still on his home
square maybe I could transfer over here
get in b4 I don't need defense over c4
anymore am I missing any tactics
is this the I mean I these guys have to
sit I can't really improve with my pawn
structure over here but what about rook
a 1b for
I think that's an idea mm-hmm it's
anticipating that maybe I could do
better with this Knight he's not really
doing anything
I don't see a better square for my
bishop but what about my knight let me
let me come back over actually I'm gonna
try it getting my knight in here maybe
that'll force it to like want to move
the knight in play here and weak in its
position a little bit I'm missing
anything
we are opposite from one another so
black to be careful I have this square
covered now with my knight let me just
throw my knight into this square right
now that's got to be a little
uncomfortable okay it's kind of
floundering what about B for now
and go somewhere else let's let's try
this idea again hang on just to move
back and forth yeah if use its assessing
this position that has white being
better when it does that because I could
have a perpetual if I want I don't want
that though could push night here I
really want to get rid of that night
let's try this rook here and then the
other rook here if this ever happens I'm
coming right back over here about a
minute oh you know what I could try
something different
I have a different idea I'm gonna put my
knight on d5 it'll take and then it'll
open up my bishop on this diagonal maybe
I could even get my Queen on f1 it's
looking to undermine again let's do this
Queen on f1 Knight here actually the now
it's now it's defended this idea of
jumping into this square about doubling
on the C file now change of plans
okay
okay with a queen go back yep hmm King
there huh Wow you're really gonna do
that you're in checking distance here
I hear pawn push Knight d4 to this
square oh oh okay you know what you know
what I have to do gotta give up
something to get something in return
here so I'm gonna work on this square
now and get right back over here right
back over here I'm gonna improve my
queen position now just a little bit
okay get my Queen a little I could jump
in right now with check and see a reason
to do that just yet though
I guess we could try this hmm
let's see it's gonna take no pawn push
now I'm not sure I don't have any time I
think I should take a draw if there's
gonna be some repetition repetition I
need to bang some time here
I gotta close it up I think maybe it'll
take I throw my knight here it still
turn out quite good this route could be
trapped maybe okay my rook belongs on d1
um I guess here
that's gonna make me play it on here I
could maybe even do a king walk that's
not out of the question it's definitely
not out of the question
King walk over to the Queen side I mean
I don't know how safe it is but my
knight is just he's really strong
I could even maybe in some lines pick up
that a pawn if the Queens come off the
board see in positions like these I
think it's still hangin it's still
assessing the position is better for
itself maybe as it was maybe a draw for
would be all right and maybe if they if
computer repeated then it would think
that white is better we're not having
that I'm just I'm not sure what I could
be doing I mean I can't move my coin my
knight here maybe it eventually would
make a pawn move just to avoid a 50 move
repetition I'm hoping for this because
then I could maybe you better rely upon
this idea of the King coming over to the
Queen side if the the King side pawn
structure becomes static so it usually
goes all the way until like move 49 and
then I think we would see h5 this isn't
helping well maybe
maybe I should yeah I have to keep
shuffling I don't really want to go here
to h2 because of Knight g5 stuff one of
these nights is indirectly in a pin okay
there we go we finally have some
progress so pawn move wasn't played but
a nightcap sure how to recapture I think
I do it with this I want to keep a piece
here keep this tactic in mind usually
there might be something with that where
can this Knight move my queen here
I could get my king all the way to I
don't know I'm gonna know I should
prepare this a little bit more no my
queen belongs on actually c3 this is the
best square defends the pond I think my
rook no longer needs to be here I don't
know you know what let's just do this
okay the knight could move but it's
never with check which would allow me to
take here I go for a King walk
I wonder I'm gonna try it cuz otherwise
we'll be here forever although I don't
know how many more hang on I got to
watch out for tricky Knight moves now if
my king wants to be on this square so
I'm gonna take a hike take a hike and
then try something over on this side of
the board can try mmm
okay Mikey needs to come back over I
need to defend and defend again and
defend again this is problem I need to
keep the clean out this is tough to play
the Queen's gonna play somewhere oh
right there
and I'm the big trouble yeah rook here
Queen here you bet you bet yeah I should
have yeah this is dead I should have
anticipated this Knight move better let
me go back right here yeah I should have
anticipated that pressure this Knight is
intolerable and when I guess then
there's peace play major piece play
against that pawn yeah
you